nun rufe ich auf den Tagesordnungspunkt
1 Abgabe einer Regierungserklärung durch
den Bundeskanzler zur Haushaltslage
hierzu liegen ein Entschließungsantrag
der Fraktion der AFD sowie ein
Entschließungsantrag der Fraktion Die
Linke vor für die Aussprache im
Anschluss an die Regierungserklärung
wurde eine Dauer von 120 Minuten
vereinbart das Wort zur Abgabe der einer
Regierungserklärung hat nun der
Bundeskanzler Herr Olaf
Scholz
frau Präsidentin liebe Kolleginnen und
Kollegen bevor ich auf das Thema unserer
heutigen Debatte eingehe möchte ich aus
aktuellem Anlass eine Sache
voranstellen in den zurückliegenden
Tagen haben die Terroristen der Hamas
endlich Geiseln
freigelassen die Geiseln ihre Freunde
und Angehörigen haben in den vergangenen
Wochen unvorstellbares durchgemacht
umso glücklicher und auch erleichterter
bin ich dass sie nun in Freiheit und in
Sicherheit
sind das unter den freigelassenen auch
mehrere deutsche sind ist ein weiterer
Grund zur Freude allen die sich in den
zurückliegenden Tag und Wochen für ihr
Schicksal eingesetzt haben in
unzähligigen vertraulichen Gesprächen
durch unermütlich Diplomatie sage ich
für diesen Einsatz von ganzem Herzen
Danke natürlich ist diese Freilassung
nur ein erster Schritt noch immer hält
die Hamas mehr als 100 Frauen Männer und
Kinder in ihrer Gewalt auch sie müssen
nun unverzüglich freigelassen werden die
Bundesregierung wird dazu weiter mit
ganzer Kraft beitragen
meine Damen und Herren ich möchte hier
im Deutschen Bundestag heute erklären
wie die Regierung mit den Folgen des
jüngsten Urteils des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts umgeht das
Gericht hat sich am 15 November erstmals
sehr detailliert und sehr weitreichend
dazu geäußert wie die sogenannte
Schuldenbremse im Grundgesetz genau
anzuwenden
ist bereits zuvor gab es in derselben
Sache ein
Eilantrag schon in diesem Beschluss
hielt das Gericht mit Blick auf die
Regelung zur Schuldenbremse fest und ich
zitiere dass die
Tatbestandsvoraussetzung der
maßgeblichen Verfassungsnorm in der
Rechtsprechung des Senats bislang noch
keine Konturierung erfahren haben noch
keine Konturierung das heißt vieles im
Umgang mit der Schuldenbremse war
bislang rechtlich eher nicht eindeutig
geklärt in dieser Lage haben wir vor
Jahren politische Einschätzung
vorgenommen die vom Verfassungsgericht
nun rechtlich verworfen worden sind das
Bundesverfassungsgericht hat dadurch
Klarheit geschaffen und das Gericht hat
das letzte Wort so ist es gute
demokratische
Tradition wissenschaftlich mag das
Urteil weiter diskutiert werden
politisch aber ist die Diskussion mit
dem Karlsruher Richterspruch beendet
mit dem Wissen um die aktuelle
Entscheidung hätten wir im Winter 2021
andere Wege beschritten Wege die das
Gericht in seinem Urteil ebenfalls
gewiesen hat das Urteil betrifft die
haushaltspraxis dieser Regierung aber
auch früherer und künftiger Regierung
das Urteil betrifft die bisherige Praxis
des Bundes genauso wie die der vieler
Länder und nicht nur weil auch die
Länder zum Teil in ganz ähnlicher Weise
wie der Bund Sondervermögen nutzen
wir haben in den vergangenen Tagen
intensiv über die Folgen des Urteils
beraten diese Beratung sind wie sollte
es anders sein noch nicht abgeschlossen
Sorgfalt geht dabei V
Schnelligkeit klar ist dieses Urteil
schafft eine neue Realität für die
Bundesregierung und für alle
gegenwärtigen und die zukünftigen
Regierung im Bund und in den
Ländern eine Realität die es allerdings
schwieriger macht wichtige und weithin
geteilte Ziele für unser Land zu
erreichen schwierig geworden ist es auch
weil Deutschland in den vergangenen zwei
Jahren von schweren unvorhergesehenen
äußeren Krisen erschüttert worden ist
und stellt das vor Herausforderung wie
unsere Republik sie in dieser
Konzentration und Härte wohl noch nicht
erlebt
hat 527 tsfälle und
69901 Neuansteckung am Tag so lauteten
die Zahlen im Corona Tagesbericht des
RKI am 8 dezember
2021 das war der Tag des Amtsantritts
dieser
Bundesregierung unser Land befand sich
seiner Zeit mitten in der deltawe
Omicron stand bevor ganze Wissens
Wirtschaftssektoren standen mit dem
Rücken zur
Wand zwei Monate später GF Russland die
Ukraine an es gibt keinen Zweifel daran
dieser Eroberungskrieg auf
europäischenem Boden schafft auf Jahre
hinaus eine vollkommen veränderte
sicherheitspolitische Lage für
Deutschland und für ganz
Europa unser Land war darauf
unzureichend vorbereitet wir haben daaus
Konsequenzen gezogen übrigens auch
gemeinsam mit ihrer Fraktion Herr märz
und dafür bin ich
dankbar Deutschland ist heute der
zweitgrößte Unterstützer der Ukraine
nach den Vereinigten Staaten von Amerika
auch bei den Waffenlieferungen wir
setzen diese Unterstützung fort so lange
wie nötig unsere zivile unterstützung
kommt noch hinzu über den Bundeshaushalt
und auch über den über die Europäische
Union Geld dass wir natürlich bei
Regierungsantritt und vor Kriegsbeginn
nicht eingeplant hatten und doch ist
diese Unterstützung von existenzieller
Bedeutung für die Ukraine das ist klar
aber auch am Ende für uns in Europa denn
niemand von uns möchte sich ausmalen
welche noch viel gravierenderen
Konsequenzen es für uns hätte wenn Putin
diesen Krieg
gewönne mehr als eine Million Ukrainer
Ukrainer Frauen Männer und Kinder sind
innerhalb weniger Wochen vor Leid und
Tod in ihrer Heimat nach Deutschland
geflogen wir haben Sie bei uns hier
aufgenommen das war
richtig das war ein Gebot der
Menschlichkeit aber natürlich bedeutet
die Aufnahme so vieler Menschen eine
enorme Anstrengung selbst ein so starkes
Land wie
Deutschland kurz nach Kriegsbeginn hat
Putin dann die gastlieferung nach
Deutschland zunächst gedrosselt und
schließlich über Nacht komplett
eingestellt nordstream 1 und eine der
Röhren von nordstream 2 wurden gesprengt
die Pipelines also die uns in den
kommenden Jahren mit günstigem Gas
versorgen sollten Gas das meine
Amtsvorgängerin immer wieder und zurecht
als die notwendige brückenenergie für
die Energiewende bezeichnet hat
mit dem Wegfall von Lieferung aus
Russland fehlten auf dem Weltmarkt
praktisch auf von einem Tag auf den
anderen 120 Milliarden Kubikmeter Gas
wohlgemerkt bei gleichbleibender
Nachfrage sie alle kennen die Folgen die
Marktpreise gingen durch die Decke
zwischenzeitlich hatten sie sich mehr
als
verzehnfacht und noch immer es Gas
unsere rückenenergie mehr als doppelt so
teuer wie zu Beginn der Energiekrise
das geht nicht spurlos vorbei an einem
Industrieland wie
Deutschland wir haben nicht nur schnell
reagiert und in Rekordzeit
flüssiggasterminals an den norddeutschen
Küsten gebaut im vergangenen Winter
2022 haben wir bis zu 200 Milliarden
Euro bereitgestellt um den Bürgerinnen
und Bürgern und unseren Unternehmen in
dieser dramatischen Notlage die
Sicherheit zu geben die sie damit sie
zurecht kommen
und es war richtig zu helfen denn so
haben wir Millionen Bürger und Bürgern
Bürgerinnen und Bürgern und vielen
Betrieben durch diese enorm schwierige
Zeit geholfen dabei war von Beginn an
klar es reicht nicht aus nur auf den
Winter 2022 23 zu schauen es ging immer
auch um den Winter 2023 24 von dem uns
nahezu alle Expertinnen und Experten
einhellig gesagt haben er können noch
kritischer werden als der
vorherige wenn wir die Mittel die 2023
für diese Hilfen nötig gewesen sind nun
noch einmal im Haushalt verankern dann
bestätigen wir lediglich was wir schon
Ende 22 beschlossen hatten was damals
nötig und richtig war und heute noch
genauso nötig und richtig ist
die coronapandemie habe ich gerade schon
erwähnt auch hier war es nötig und
richtig dass wir noch in der
Vorgängerregierung umfangreiche
coronahilfen beschlossen haben über
mehrere Jahre hinweg auch hier ging es
um Sicherheit und um eine Perspektive
für die Bürgerin und Bürger so und nur
so ist Deutschland Bess durch diese
jahrhundertpandemie gekommen als viele
andere
Länder es war nötig und richtig liebe
Kolleginnen und Kollegen dass wir
unmittelbar nach dem Beginn des
russischen angriffskriegs gegen die
Ukraine ein Sondervermögen beschlossen
haben um unsere Bundeswehr über die
kommenden Jahre hinweg zu stärken und
besser
aufzustellen und es war nötig und
richtig meine Damen und Herren dass wir
den den Bürgern und Bürgern in
rheinlandfalz und neudrinwestfalen den
Bürgern und Bürgern im Atal geholfen
haben als ihr Hab und Gut 2021 von den
Wassermassen zerstört
wde natürlich ist der Wiederaufbau nach
solch einer Katastrophe nicht in 5
Monaten beendet so ein Wiederaufbau
oftmals von Null dauert
Jahre wir schulden den Opfern und den
Betroffenen vor Ort dass wir ihn dabei
solidarisch zur Seite stehen so wie wir
es gemeinsam beschlossen und versprochen
haben wir wollen die Hilfen für das atil
und die energiepreishilfen daher noch
einmal im Haushalt für dieses Jahr
verankern und von der Ausnahmeregel in
Artikel 115 des Grundgesetzes Gebrauch
machen so schlagen wir es im
Zusammenhang mit dem Nachtragshaushalt
2023 vor das Bundesverfassungsgericht
hat diesen Weg in seinem Urteil
ausdrücklich gewiesen mehr noch es hat
bestätigt dass dem Gesetzgeber in
außergewöhnlichen Notsituationen wie
Artikel 115 absatz 2 Satz 6 sie vorsieht
ein einschätzungs und
Beurteilungsspielraum
zukommt eine neue Realität schafft das
Urteil allerdings insofern als Hilfen in
solchen Notsituation nun jedes Jahr vom
Bundestag neu beschlossen werden müssen
aber auch neu beschlossen werden
können damit trägt das Gericht dem
Umstand Rechnung dass die üblichen
Spielräume eines regulären Haushalts in
solchen Notsituation eben nicht
ausreichen wie also gehen wir mit dieser
Realität nun konkret um erst
noch am Tag des Urteils hat der
Bundesfinanzminister Ausgaben aus dem
Wirtschaftsplan des Klima und
transformationsfonds gesperrt von der
Sperre ausgenommen sind Verpflichtung
die der Bund schon vertraglich
eingegangen ist ausgenommen sind
außerdem Maßnahmen die die
Energieeffizienz und den Einsatz
erneuerbare Energien im Gebäudebereich
fördern das Gebieten die
Rechtssicherheit und die Verlässlichkeit
gegenüber den bürgerinen und
Bürgern
mit einem Nachtragshaushalt für 2023
werden wir zudem die Rücklage des Klima
und transformationsfonds um 60
Milliarden Euro
verringern
zweitens wir haben Vorsorge getroffen
damit nicht automatisch neue finanzielle
Verpflichtungen für die kommenden Jahre
eingegangen werden und zwar solange bis
wir alle Fragen präzise beantwortet
haben die sich nach dem Urteil stellen
wichtig ist laufende Ausgaben sind davon
nicht betroffen der Staat wird seinen
Aufgaben auch weiterhin
gerecht ich sage das auch an die
Bürgerinnen und Bürger gerichtet die
aufgrund mancher wilder Vorschläge und
manch gezielter Falschmeldung in den
sozialen Medien verunsichert sind in
ihrem Alltag hier und heute ändert das
Urteil des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
nichts völlig unabhängig davon ob sie
Kindergeld oder barfk bekommen eine
Rente oder wohn
drittens wir stellen sicher dass der
laufende Haushalt 223 allen Vorgaben des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts entspricht das
Kabinett hat gestern dem Entwurf eines
Nachtragshaushaltes für 223 zugestimmt
dieser wurde dem Bundestag als
Haushaltsgesetzgeber zugeleitet zudem
werden wir den wie schon gesagt
vorschlagen ein Beschluss gemäß Artikel
115 Absatz 2 des Grundgesetzes zu fassen
ich habe es gerade
erwähnt damit sichern wir nachträglich
die energiepreisbremsen für 2023 ab die
im Zuge des russischen angriffskriegs
gegen die Ukraine erforderlich geworden
sind das ist wichtig für die Bürgerin
und Bürger für unsere krankenhuser und
für die Unternehmen und damit sichern
wir auch die Unterstützung für die vom
Hochwasser bet famen in reinlandalz und
Nordrheinwestfalen wichtig ist wir
stellen dadurch die bereits vom
Bundestag bewilligtmittel zur
krisenbewältung auf eine andere
Rechtsgrundlage so tragen wir den
Vorgaben des Verfassungsgerichts
Rechnung aber eben auch der Tatsache
dass die energieprreiskrise jetzt wohl
definitiv noch nicht ganz beendet ist
und die Zerstörung nach einer Flut noch
nicht beseitigt
sind dass wir die energiepreisbremsen
gleich wohl zu Beginn des kommenden
Jahres beenden können hat einen
einfachen Grund inzwischen sind überall
in Deutschland wieder Strom und
Gastarife verfügbar die zwar deutlich
höher liegen als vor der Krise aber
meist unterhalb der Obergrenzen die wir
für die preisbremsen gezogen haben und
ebenfalls spürbar unterhalb der Preise
im vergangenen Herst und Winter unsere
gastspeicher haben wir zudem so gut
gefüllt dass wir nicht mit plötzlichen
Preissprüngen rechnen klar ist aber auch
sollten die Preise für Energie dennoch
erneut unerwartet dramatisch steigen
sind wir jeder Zeit in der Lage
kurzfristig zu
handeln vierens die Regierungsfraktion
haben vergangene Woche beschlossen über
die des Urteils auf den Haushaltsentwurf
für 2024 ausführlich zu beraten dafür
haben sie den Abschluss der
Haushaltsberatung verschoben das gibt
uns Zeit vorhandene Spielräume im
Haushalt auszuloten Schwerpunkte zu
setzen und natürlich auch Ausgaben zu
beschränken zusammen mit dem Bundestag
arbeiten nun intensiv daran alle
Beschlüsse die für 2024 nötig sind so
schnell wie möglich zu treffen denn die
Bürgerin und Bürger und unsere
Unternehmen brauchen in unruhigen Zeiten
Klarheit und ganz klar
ist die Bürgerin und Bürger können
darauf vertrauen dass der Staat seine
Zusagen ihnen gegenüber
einhält wir lassen niemanden allein mit
den Herausforderung
akell zuun
haben das habe ich im vergangenen Jahr
versprochen und dabei
bleibt weiß jetzt nicht wie ihren Spaß
da interpretieren soll aber vielleicht
Soter
Einfall am Ende geht es dabei auch um
etwas
Grundsätzliches nämlich um den
Zusammenhalt in unserem Land um den
Sozialstaat es geht um die Frage steht
jeder für sich allein wenn es schwierig
wird oder haken wir uns unter ich bin
zutiefst überzeugt wir alle kommen
besser zurecht wenn wir niemanden
zurücklassen
wir alle kommen besser zurecht wenn wir
uns den Herausforderung Seite an Seite
stellen klar ist auch in unserer
Unterstützung der Ukraine und bei der
Bewältigung der Energiekrise dürfen wir
auf keinen Fall nachlassen das wäre
nicht verantwortlich das würde unsere
Zukunft
gefährden und zugleich wäre es ein
schwerer ein unverzeilicher Fehler über
die Bewältigung dies akuten
Herausforderung die Modernisierung
unseres Landes zu
vernachlässigen diese Modernisierung ist
nötig und richtig sie schafft die
Voraussetzung für gute Arbeitsplätze und
eine starke Wirtschaft damit das
Fundament unseres künfen Wohlstands
gesichert bleibt natürlich haben auch
die regierungschefinen und
Regierungschefs der Länder das
allergrößte Interesse daran D zuk
Investition bei Ihnen vor Ort auch
zustande kommen Investitionen etwa in
schiffindustrie in klimafreundlichen
Stahl oder
Batteriefabrik uns ein darüber hinaus
eine Überzeugung nur wenn sich
Deutschland modernisiert werden wir in
der Lage sein auch künftig auf
unvorhergesehene Krisen kraftvoll zu
reagieren meine Damen und Herren wir
haben zu Beginn unserer Regierung
entschieden nicht länger zuzusehen wie
Deutschlands Infrastruktur
verfällt und zwar klar wir müssen jetzt
kraftvoll in die Modernisierung
Deutschlands investieren wir müssen
jetzt dafür sorgen dass wir in
Deutschland die Transformation unserer
Wirtschaft hinbekommen und als starkes
Industrieland wettbewerbsfähig
bleiben
und wir müssen jetzt alles daran setzen
die Energiewende in Deutschland und
Europa endlich voranzubringen die von
vielen Vorgängerregierung versprochen
wurde aber ni alss wirklich
umgesetzt wir müssen jetzt den
Reformstau auflösen wir müssen jetzt
Tempo machen nach Jahren des
Stillstands
an all diesen Zielen arbeitet die von
mir geführte Bundesregierung von Tag 1
an die großen modernisierungsfororhaben
für unser Land sind nicht hinfällig
geworden im Gegenteil
egal wo man hinschaut ob in die USA oder
nach Frankreich nach China oder Japan
überall sind rionen dabei massiv in die
Zukunft zu
investieren weltweit investieren Länder
in moderne und digitale Infrastruktur in
saubere Energieversorgung und in
klimfreundliche
Technologien wir sind mitten im Aufbruch
in eine neue era vergleichbar in seiner
Dimension nur mit dem Aufbruch in das
Industriezeitalter jetzt schon in den
allernächsten Jahren entscheidet sich wo
künftig Wertschöpfung stattfindet wo
Innovation und Wohlstand zu Hause sind
in einer klimaneutralen
Welt
ich will dass Deutschland ganz vorne
dabei ist denn es geht für uns alle um
viel es geht um sichere Arbeitsplätze es
geht um eine wettbewerbsfähige
Wirtschaft es geht um ein gutes Leben
für kommende Generationen und es geht um
unsere Fähigkeit auch künftige Krisen
sicher zu
bewältigen diesen klaren Prämissen
beraten wir jetzt über den Haushalt für
das kommende Jahr mit der nötigen Ruhe
und in Verantwortung für unser Land
darauf können die Bürger und Bürger sich
verlassen dafür stehe ich als
Bundeskanzler ich danke
ihnen Bundeskanzler Olaf Scholz hier mit
der Regierungserklärung in der quasi für
jeden etwas drin war er hat sich hier
als souveräner Staatsmann gezeigt der
den Bürgern verspricht dass alles gut
wird er hat noch mal erklärt wie es dazu
kommen konnte dass man jetzt einen
Nachtragshaushalt für das Jahr
2023 einbringen muss er hat an einer
Stelle gesagt dass wir
energiebeisbremsen zu Beginn des
kommenden Jahres beenden können da hat
die Sozialdemokratie nicht mitgeklatscht
an der Stelle und er hat an ander Stelle
gesagt dass man aber doch als moderne
Industrienation jetzt nicht stehen
bleiben kann sondern dass jetzt
modernisiert werden muss daraus kann man
interpretieren dass er gewillt wäre auch
weitere Schritte fiskalisch zu gehen
aber zu fiskalischen Schritten hat er
leider gar nichts gesagt und das mag den
ein oder anderen ein wenig enttäuschen
ein typischer Olaf Scholz will ich mal
sagen der hier etwas trohend über allem
das kennen wir auch von Angler merke
natürlich
versucht hat die Bürger zu beruhigen er
habe alles im Griff